signori
scusatemi scusatemi oggi iniziato tardi
ho iniziato speri che tolgo la storia
che ci ho messo che brutta in culo io e
storico le brutte le tolgo sempre
scusatemi iniziato tardi perché sono
scemo per cosa è successo e vi sentite
innanzitutto che sono faccia matricole
merda vi sentite ci si sente e successo
che stavo registrando no stavo
registrando alle
[Musica]
8 alle otto e mezza ho finito di
registrare e ho detto vabbè dai adesso
mi godo la serata
minchia cielo live e niente sono rimasti
che non avevo ancora mangiato e tra
mezz'ora ve l'avevo detto mica ho
provato a cucinare in fretta
solo che che già non so cucinare
normalmente se cocino di fretta ancora
peggio quindi se ho messo io invece che
morire sull'in cucina dico che faccio
avrebbe un po più tardi scusa è colpa
mia non ho visto l'orario e non sto
registrando tante in sti giorni perché
mi sto portando avanti per le feste
natalizie visto che anch'io ho una
famiglia e quindi passano del tempo con
loro mi sono visto portato un po avanti
quindi capitano per quello sono un po
grazie alexis per la donazione o
attivato l'audio delle donazioni che mi
si sente attraverso le casse del mio
computer
ditemi se vi entra 20 volte l'audio se
va bene cioè fatemi fatemelo presente
nei commenti se dà fastidio fossi nel
senso si sente mille volte e bene e
grazie alexis per la donazione grazie
simone scusatemi quindi far questo
disguido dovuto alla pizza che ho
mangiato viva la pizza viva la patata
tutte le cose giuste per te che adesso
apro all'inizio nation e direbbe allora
allora fare live
la sera è molto molto più bello che fare
la domenica pomeriggio perché la sera io
sono proprio apro la mente rilassa relax
relax time quindi quando parto mi mi
rilasso quindi superfluo sono proprio
contento
si no dicevo l'audio delle notifiche
beta rette
quando l'ho sentito quando c'è una
donazione da 5 euro superiore
quindi se vi da fastidio che che entra
più volte se entra un loop tipo matrix
lo tolgo se no no bene bene grazie pace
agazzi massimo ripetiamo alien da dove
avevo rimasti allora oggi fa lungo la
live di mezz'ora perché ho iniziato
mezz'ora più tardi quindi finire a
mezzanotte ok se dovete andare a dormire
easy peasy perché tanto la live rimane
aperta come se rimane aperta rimanere
pubblica sul canale vevo dire ciao
andrea grazie mille
allora non vi spariamo i giochi che
destò registrando quindi andiamo
direttamente su alien isolazione di
aliens co.pe una bottiglia d'acqua già
che ci sono perché mi sono indicati per
le vado a fare apreda bottiglia d'acqua
e arrivo tanto vi lascio con la intro il
gioco
[Musica]
gesù cristo di comanda bellis the ride
bono ma facciamo una citazione di tutti
gli streamer cosa è successo tra 3 c o
basta questa cosa di me ciccio basta che
travaso di palle
durante la settimana risolviamo prossima
la galli da un po cambia connessione è
uscito benissimo
ciao amici oggi sono a carico minchia
come si finisce st serie cazzo
no non è vero la finiremo mai ho detto
quella parola cosa ci mi è scappata
scusatemi non faccio editing quindi alle
volte mi scappano perdonatemi se le live
ogni tanto me ne esco cosa volevo dirvi
meglio mi sono dimenticato lo vivono
dire porca ha sì mi è passata la febbre
quindi posso registrare a piena piena
energia all ultimo terra uno zombie però
adesso mi è passata la febbre
sto bene molto bene comprate acqua
valmora
ok la mia agenzia mi ammazzerà per
questa volta è un fatto lei smetteranno
ovviamente improvvisa sapete che c'è
gente cgh guardate me adesso è un
discorso in precedente che pensa che io
quando faccio vedere un qualche cosa sia
un play tipo io padova bevo la coca cola
non nelle foto magari è venduto fa il
placement alla coca cola quindi io non
posso bere niente di di marca perché se
non placement oppure non lo so se la
maglietta della nike have al placement
alla nike magari quindi mi faceva ridere
solo perché noi noi influenze
chiamiamoci questo termine da schifo va
a vomitare come qualsiasi cosa abbiamo è
uno sponsor a qualcuno che va bene ogni
tanto è vero ogni tanto è vero
quest'anno sempre madonna da quindi
acqua la beve tè e si toglie la 7
compratela che è successo questa mattina
intro strana che è successo sega la
madre andiamo da allora stai meglio è
stata sempre chiara ciao chiara sto
molto meglio da dio no stop di scherzi
molto meglio passata al 95 per cento con
il 5 per cento che è rimasta mela merito
chao li ha
siamo stati tra i primi iscritti vuole
sapere quando votiva resistenze before
the storm and a life in strange before
the storm elis due live 2 the storm lo
quello prix ebri quel non lo so quando
lo farò quei due fini ha prima l'hai
vista da inge normale l'ultimo the feast
range magari in un periodo di intermezzo
tra una serie e l'altra la sera lo
faccio tanto deve durare un paio di ore
è giustamente ciao mickey grazie alla
nazione favino problemi a dirlo siccome
lo sa mezzo mondo sono autolesionisti in
italia mi consiglieresti ad ora non
farlo questo è un consiglio molto basico
verona data non farlo e avevo un'amica
che faceva questa cosa qua e le sono
stato vicino è migliorata molto e quindi
ci sono persone che ti vogliono bene ed
è una cosa molto importante che tu
capisca perché non tutti ne sono
consapevoli e sono sicuro che tu hai
degli amici e quando sei triste quando
fai queste cose qua cerca la compagnia
ed è quello che con i miei amici ha
sempre funzionato quello poi io non
penso di essere data la persona più
adatta per dare consigli
in questo ambito però se sabrina però
poi ci sono io dai screen sponde del
bacino non fare queste cose brutte ciao
patto ciao fabio ciao massimo
ciao sarà il sovrano live mentre sto
tornando dallo shopping natalizio dopo
aver guidato va in fabbrica io faccio la
live dopo che ho guidato
cominciamo premi il tasto qualsiasi non
funziona a parigi no no no mi chiama all
inizio partita mi chiami stanno
cancellando i salvataggi bio char
headline grazie in redazione ciao alexis
potrei giocare con te un giorno quando
voi a fort knight p pericolo
ovviamente sì
non è che non gioca four nights rob ve
lo farò solo per te alexis ciao martyna
ciao ormai appuntamento fisso ai pesci
mancherebbe altro
giacché guardando il barbara d'urso non
guardate le mie live c'è qualche
problema
alexia fedarazione devo capire cosa devo
fare
usa l'ascensore la creatura intrappolata
all'esterno liste vasto paul quindi
appare la creatura non c'è più trovava
arresto della scuola fronte all whites è
ok
quello che mi ha espulso se vi ricordate
nella stazione perché waits è quello che
mi aveva escluso insieme ad alien quel
pezzo come bravo ragazzo li quindi
dobbiamo trovarle file il culetto
vorrei anche precisare che io sono al 4
al quarto la quarta live di halimi
soleil sono già sette ore di gioco e non
ho mai usato un medikit perché non c'è
dio
quindi adesso li prenderò c'è lo
prenderò perché so dove si trova
[Musica]
ciò fa vidi questo notare sono tua
vecchissima fa
quanti anni hai 85 pro ti chiami alexia
grazie mille molto gentile chokri bat
grazie mille ribat number one si nun se
l'amica presa con wesley ma c'è chi c'è
un fucile a pompa
sto male e offri culetti successo lì la
samp e genoa
ce l'ho solo con waits chi devo tirare
una fucilata in faccia signori mi hanno
visto mi sa che non mi hanno v come si
apresta portato porco demonio è tanto
cha la serranda luca sei scarso potresti
far passare i proiettili buchi ma non
sei capace a centrare i buchi pirla
ripristino alla corretta in cartellino
di presenza va bene però non si doveva
il sì sì bravo braud spreca ancora un po
di proietti che sei a sparare topo gigio
bravo complimenti dario moccia
in che rapporti sono con dario bocciata
da io ne ho letto un messaggio al volo
non l'ho letto neanche bene dove la
ripristino la corrente immagino più
indietro adesso vado a ripristinarla
magari libro e così sto ricettario
moccia e rispondo prima domanda sua ci
sono in buoni rapporti non lo sento da
un bagni tipo tre anni 23 anni è però
cavolo per me è sempre stato un punto di
riferimento darione sempre da stormi
inchiesta corrente no seriamente perché
c'è dove giorno la mappa e da un botto
che non lo sento mi farebbe piacere di
sentirlo grande dario number one equa
comunque portello bloccato devo andare
qua per ripristinare corrente non posso
entrare
sale impianti che sia corrente dei
poteri sicurezza ho capito è che è
chiuso come sarà però non mi ama non si
stupisce di chiunque grazie e chiara
spero di poter parlare con me un giorno
mi sono cagato addosso a me qua a ma
[ __ ] afam noked app store da non
si apre di no che succede si muove sta a
fare io mi ero nascosto
sto male vabbè livaja ripristina
e stai zitto tu eh sì certo ne parleremo
un giorno grazie per la donazione per il
supporto come sempre perché sia sempre
presente però sappi scusami non pensavo
di poter entrare dentro
sappi che quando ci sarai io quando
quando ne avrà bisogno di regolare le
faccio sempre
quindi ti aspetto se può essere d'aiuto
insomma
ciao ale grazie mille sono un tuo
vecchissimo fan anche tu ci avrai 80
anni di sicuro ai 50mila iscritti allora
sì che chanel e 80 anni grazie a un
bacio anche a te piace tanto lost vera
davvero anche mia zia si chiama così un
bel nome e mi fa piacere che ti piaceva
perché una deve essere più belle mai
fatte bravo su sì che capisce i granata
empi grande che non è un kit medico va
fanno ca sort del tubificio né domani
lorenzo tironi pochi spicci che vi
rimangono dal nick reilly
poi uno sconto sulla dotazione però non
si applicano a farla però grazie se
molto gentile comunque anch'io ho preso
una roba sul black friday che non posso
dire se non facciamo che faccio gli
sponsor
si sono bloccate le robe laterali della
webcam è vero a è vero ogni tanto si
pagano sti cosi è bene non ci vogliamo
di registrarsi basta devo riavviarlo li
vogliono
poi grazie di avermelo diretto e o bs
ogni tanto fa le bizze le pizze
il fatto è che io comunque un fucile a
pompa avevo cinque colpi non sprecati
già quattro quindi perfetto potessi mai
trovare dei colpi in giro sarebbe ok no
queste chiusa e cattivo qualcosa qua
batterie per la torcia non si sa chi è
che rilevo sul rodano ogni tanto fa b
c'è qua sotto
ci devo passare tutto 18 permetti ti sta
succedendo
devo cambiare la frase dei bot e ragga
scusatemi lasciate stare il motto che
continua a dire che fare del fascio live
la domenica lasciatelo perdere
[Musica]
scusatemi per i bot però sono pigro ok
non c'ho voglia yard per la causa
ora ecco cosa aspetta prima file del
computer ma ovviamente spento perché non
c'è corrente
[Musica]
ciao mi nichi c'è scritto su install va
bene rispondo per un attimo
grazie mille presidente daiwa ben un
bacino thorne al dipartimento
dell'ufficiale attivato al corrente
quindi è ufficiale
e ufficiale che posso tornare al
dipartimento lo figlio
quello non mi ha visto e scemo ma tu sai
che sono un nemico ma no mi sa che non
lo stupro sono nemici questi di morire
prima turno il gioco e va bene non fa
niente vado io controllo di orco demonio
muori prima tu
ecco bravo sarà la priorità di mont di
morte correremo casari incidenti dove
vado mi servirebbe uscire da può che
andare a qualche parte ho trovato
colpito i lanciafiamme molto meno
mi chiedo quando attivato il sound la
divan donazione al secondo ragazzi
aspettate un attimo non riesco a
gestirla aiuto non si apre e non si può
fare aiuto aiuto
sto mare aspetta che tanto non mi
raggiungono sono scemi non è vero non
sono scemi morto demonio
corri e lo vedo dove vado aspetto che
devo capire dovete aprire le porte
immediatamente ed è veloce aia
porca vacca l'ha uccisa allora ci ha
pensato lui elimina i pc a pompa miss
alcuni colpi di fucile a pompa mi
servono chi è questo uccidete lui c'è la
torcia umana ii vc lo è ma premi che
sono fatti di cartapesta di uomini vi
servono i colpi del pool c del fucile a
pompa
spiega mag scusate ragazzi sono il
momento concitatissimo c'è bisogno di
concentrazione doveva dove cosa aiuto ho
preso l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho preso
perchè sorpreso dove vado dove dove vado
dove vado dove il po apri apri non apre
eccolo no vabbè reagan ci credo pieno di
gente in da caso
non raga sto male cioè devi aprire tutte
le porte a prima aprea p veloci veloci
veloci
apri quanto tempo lo zio devi aprire zio
devi aprire di aprile apri apri porta la
porta fosse questa porco demonio non
raga dovete aprire la porta se non
aprite la porta un casino
aprite la porta
ci crede ragazzo
l'altro fa schifo
ah ok
minchia
nora che non posso morire adesso potuto
la strada parco schifo lavano mancata la
mancata lo sapevo che finiva così va
bene
haymarket 6 fa v6 perché il cane si
insegue la coda perché lista in culo non
meriti di vivere però grazie però non
meri però grazie però non me
ciao giorgio grazie mille ciò play gamer
piper thank you so much of a samurai con
il deficiente ragano novità che farò va
della vita
adesso da questo momento in poi inizia a
essere importante quindi devo trovare
devo assolutamente trovare il mediche
presso non lo trovo cielo nel deretano
fisso
ciao mario grazie mille ciale intorno
giocare che mario è no o demonio morto
scusa vi però dai casing howard evo devo
prendere la mira come si deve io non
capisco come si spara in sto gioco
perché ogni volta sono storto con una
morte ma ricordi
bene facciamo un pò più di un po più
calma ok mente si sa la gente deve
sparare alla gente nel momento in cui
c'e alien gesù al tonfo elettrico la mia
salvezza lanciafiamme che sta succedendo
veramente sono sporco già come la morte
per perché la milano
il mio obiettivo è prendere i proiettili
e sopravvivere allo stesso momento però
un macello
vabbè via
ecco
da che parte era andato prima nomi
coordinato no se si sia iniziato gioco
ho ricordi cori per i cori corridori che
ripetono
apri tutto aperto perfetto se dio vuole
forse ci riescono sbrana mazzate anche
altra gente
un'era che sia aperta prima
non ci credo ma ti pare che si è chiusa
la porta si è chiusa la fama a cagare
vabbè se ci si mettono pure le porte
sparava meglio mia nonna ci hai ragione
il giro ho sparato veramente storto
primo parco schifo prima che per
aiutarli ci mette un'ora e mezza che
pirla che pirano ha regalato il pirla
deficiente bello che non ho proiettili
capito quindi sta parte proprio
difficile cioè volevo dire una vita non
l'avevo già detto ragazzi forse non ve
l'ho detto prima non mi dicono più la
live lungo fino alla mezzanotte perché
ho iniziato mezz'ora testardi capito
quindi facevo sempre due ore e mezza
invece fini alle undici e mezza finisca
mezzanotte ok il botto lo devo cambiare
non l'ho ancora cambiato il motto della
chat te li puoi creare i medici però non
c'è non so che cosa per crearli
io sì
anzi
devo vedere se
beh
no
skopje
non mi si chiude di nuovo perché se mi
si chiede ancora guarda ok
problema che è mosso
è come se stesso cacciando i veneziani
non puoi andare da loro direttamente che
sono lì dietro
no
spara gli sbagli essere umano inutile
sparagli no regga senza il kit medico è
difficilissimo senza il kit è veramente
un casino porco schifo come la prima
volta che ci ho provato mi era andata
benissimo
cioè non so come sia possibile mi è
andata bene solo la prima volta ma è
difficilissimo
i robot mi servono non posso buttarlo
giù perché se li butto giù mi fanno
fuori quelli col fucile accontano quindi
in teoria sarebbe utile tenermi simon
dai ci riproviamo
i provini che il seno è la prima volta
l'ho fatto ed è andata benissimo non ce
la farò mai più farlo
ma come ma come ma come una come dove
sono gli androidi ma cristo che si
svegliano quando ci hanno voglia ma
scusami
che palle che palle però quando devo
aspettare ogni volta perché si svegliano
cristo che fastidio
minchia sto gioco quando certe cose mi
dava troppo fastidio alterna momenti
epici al momento inter di trattamento di
parole allucinante in difficoltà media
con così poca vita è se in realtà io non
sto giocando modalità non sto giocando
in modalità media sociale modalità
impossibile perché la mia vita non è non
l'ho mai curata
aspettiamo 6 ore tanto guarda
sì chi rispondono grazie lo stesso non
c'è bisogno che continui a donare va
bene così davvero basta basta
sì risponde promessa basta non fare qui
va bene così
grazie mille c'è bisogno purtroppo
troppo gli spot sono morte a me la
meglio in questa frase ci sta veramente
poco però ciao sam
allora i consiglieri una canzone che ti
piace bologna rocks di dei queen
la porta non si apre una la morte da
questo ce la fa vi sono anche oggi ciao
francia how are you my friend adesso ti
faccio sapere se io sto bene un altro
difende il suo ciclo tedesco uscire le
notizie piatta li mortacci del masso
togliti essere inutile tre ne sa come ne
ha tre nella xii prima mi ricordo male
io prima aveva dodici colpi di fucile
buono trovati tre ma come ne ho trovati
tre dai serio praga prima ne aveva 12
libri se va bene se ci si mette per una
sfiga che parte ma non c'era un androide
prima non lo so ma meglio muovere il
culetto
[Musica]
mario sei ingrassato noi e toby e
ingrassato
le ovvero ranieri prima di mi dovevo
ammazzare subito se non sono cazzi miei
a chi è che ha vinto
finché non ho ucciso subito voi non
avete armi però sono sparisce la gente e
mi dite dove si va perché se noi siamo
morti tutti dove vado
costretto se questa si apre
ha quindi poteva evitare di sparare alla
t come pensano meritavano un falletto dc
dove un corso pensato ecco io ad un vero
morto prima di salvare ovvia me
ovviamente ovviamente andrebbe delle
team bohemian rhapsody sì però io non
posso mai andare a vedere i film appena
escono perché se vado a vederli appena
escono faccio il raduno nella sala del
cinema quindi devo aspettare sempre un
volto di tempo per andare dal film
quando non gli riusciva quasi nessuno in
sala capita però sì lo vado a vedere che
detta così sembra una roba tipo come
suonasse siglando il latte non me ne
frega un cazzo della di variabili subito
i film non posso farlo però vorrei sia
andare a vederlo assolutamente perché
potete vederlo subito guardatelo jimmyx
nutella bravo grazie cosa sempre giusta
da dire
ma decidi cosa fare la tua vita per fare
in fretta andare
no ragazzi sono scemo io non trovo la a
parte che non mi hanno seguito gli
androidi fino qua quindi bene secondo me
la gente in questo gioco scemo
[Musica]
meno male che posso aspettare pensare
perché so dove devo andare quindi
perfetto mi dai una mano
vedo veramente che se poco utile dove
dove due righe mi dai una mano zio ti
prego tutta quando pallini solutions
cosa postale porterei sul canale e non
l'ho ancora deciso lo decido appena
finisco io non ho ancora deciso di cd
live
intendi ha forse devo fare qualcosa fa
no perché no
non so cosa devo fare
porco demonio torna così centrare
capitano non mi ci fate riva niente non
ha sparato la notte indietro
ecco vedi che non dovevo tornare
indietro volavo detto io cava ai
problemi seri passo atteso
[Musica]
carica per il tonfo tron era di qua alla
fine
figurati se dai dai
cavalcante no è chiusa dovete aprire
lega nord e via di riaprirle subito in
media tipo in un nanosecondo della prole
devi aprire subito le deve aprire blob
roll e devi aprire immediatamente però
però la porta sprecato il mio ultimo
proiettile grazie mille 0 trova un
passaggio alternativo bene guarda
perfetto non ho più colpi per il pompa
ottimo maledizione poi colpi di fucile a
pompa li trovi solo dalla gente figurati
qui devo ammazzare gente vede
c'è qualcuno qui li mortacci vostri la
vedo una botola secondo me c'è una
botola nascosta qui da qualche parte
però non la vedo
porca vacca ah se solo si aprisse una di
queste porte ma non si aprono paga non
ho più proiettili e cioè se mi arriva un
bot
l'androide ciò nel campo anzi di brutto
poi cosa faccio fatto di sopra di nuovo
ma doveva porca vacca difficilissimo
alien dove ali el abbiamo espulso amico
mio non c'è più
in teoria non ci dovrebbe più essere
pure naga
ma vabbè alla sede scemi il soldato
prima da una parte che doveva andare
prima dall'altra va beh l'indicatore mi
indica la via siamo sicuri ma sai che è
vero ci avete ragione l'indicatore
indica dove devo andare
ma io non avevo mai fatto caso questa
cosa bene me lo ricorderò grazie del
suggerimento sapete che non l'avevo mai
capito
quindi se non so dove andare
dovrebbe portarsi qui
ho visto quello che avete visto voi ecco
non si stava morendo stava correndo sul
posto vabbè
questa è una violazione della sicurezza
e mezza tonnellata
zio poi poi poi circumnaviga armi parco
demonio stavo scherzando lo sto
prendendo per il culo della serie poi
puoi andarmi intorno quanto voi non
prenderei mai io invece mi stava
prendendo
ti piace questo no vabbè non sprechiamo
ancora fuori sfotterla gente mai
sfottere gli androidi qualcuno che ha
dei proiettili così di fucile a pompa no
e così proprio veniva io stupido che mi
viene stato manda porca vacca colori e
va vicino quindi non possono capire
c'è veramente mi segue ovunque o specchi
c'è una botola qua è veloce veloce che
la gente è giusto
perché non ha ben capito come funziona
su indicatori però forse ci avete
ragione davvero mi indica dove devo
andare
ok perfetto con il mio letale tonfa
carica per il tonfo otto colpi del tonfo
un altro popolo anche lanciafiamme aver
caricato come possibile chi uguali
questi posti porca vacca ma che ho fatto
il giro e pirla vabbè che il tipo non mi
segue questo lo dovrei spostare no
luciano android è morto che non è morto
quindi non mi avvicino lo sapevo che non
è morto lo sapevo che era morto lo
sapevo piccolo no dai
no raga non ci credo perché non ho una
domanda che io il medic it il medic it
cristo mi dà troppo fastidio che la
gente mi tocca e muoio mi dà troppo
fastidio
sapevo pure colori era per terra li
mortacci sua nonna lo sapevo anche
quello il problema
porca vacca che fastidio che mi dava
questa gente mamma mia giro l'idea
rigoni la un mazzo subito gli do fuoco
in un atom fatta in faccia dov'è per lui
lasciamo perdere che pezzente o stava
fermo vi chiamiamo ammazzato riuscito
ammazzarmi lurido pezzo di latta
ebbene
scusami eh no
sì
cosa fare ti svegli quando ci hai voglia
il file android e quando vuoi prima mori
per gli spettacoli gesù cristo cioè la
resurrezione
cos'è spiegami cribbio che che che
rottura di palle non avere il medico
possono non metterti il medic it dal piu
di meta gioco che salvi dai vieni giù
veloce c'è limite se devo sprecare dei
colpi lanciafiamme per un [ __ ]
android
anzi sai che c'è gli sparo non cerchiamo
di sparo questa roba
bello il tonfo utilissimo una
grandissima arma al tonfo gli salva la
vita in senza quelli occasioni ma
l'aveva duro altro è morto subito non
muoiono mai subito coi colpi in testa
boh ci siamo non mi voglio quando attivo
la corrente ma qua siamo spesso capitale
siamo
sì esattamente dove pensavo di essere
quindi tutto giusto mi servirebbero dei
car delle cariche per la per il
lanciafiamme
se riuscissi a trovarle
no ovviamente devo andar via l'altro poi
dove dove l'ho preso no no non c'è
sarebbe fico sotto rossi le cariche per
i lanciafiamme esattamente dove ho
trovato però no
cosa che c'è di qua figata
vabbè dai belga frank c'è gente ancora
ma basta un ciao hai sono tornato qui
hai visto
ripley sono tutti morti
meno male perché rischia di restare qui
si chiude portarli a non far entrare
nessuno i figli di una persona un'altra
volta su questa nave dopo che ti hanno
tradito tutti sei un po stupida però
lasciamola morire tanto sono io che la
comando perfetto se ti da fastidio con
qualcuno ti tocca amori fai più bella
giorno giocare a kingdom hearts and
peace vedete i controlli rotti di blu e
possono dirci devo vederlo no no guarda
meno male che non gioca fu già kingdom
hearts in cui c'è questa è la
motivazione cosa a sé o riaperto la
portali meno male quindi devo ritornare
nel punto dove c'era la gente alla mela
navetta ok
in teoria cui ci dovrebbe essere medikit
qua in questo punto quindi se dio vuole
non ci torno alla navetta
pubblichiamo se ci torni qua davanti a
sinistra speriamo e non è detto però in
teoria a destra
tutto in fondo eccoci no non è allora
quello che dicevo io a parte per
prendere nel merito il prova me non
importa se andiamo subito che non so se
di cuori altro posso andare soli qua
veloce veloce veloce la navetta veloce
veloce veloce una retta veloce veloce
veloce veloce quanto tempo sta la vetta
minchia neanche gttv torino e così lento
dai apriti dai quanto tempo non si apre
siamo qui tanto inattesa quanto madonna
la stai fabbricando st navetta
mamma mia
le big brother apostrofare dieci anni
bona
allora me ne frega niente l'obiettivo
della l'obiettivo del del gioco devo
trovare il medico medici la prima porta
quanto tempo workplace luciano spero sia
qua no valle dall'altra parte
no non me ne frega niente se non c'è in
questo mese di aprile
ok forse dall'altra scala di tutto
uguale al suo posto
lawrence lawrence io ti ringrazio dio ti
ringrazio apri sta roba
raga raga
raga
c'è il segreto su come diventare
youtuber di successo come
[Musica]
veloce e lo trovo prezzi giocarci col
quale questi sono tutti ben guardare non
sono buono manco così io primo secondo
col quarto o sogni dai dai
io c'è o cristo un anno e mezzo per
trovato schifo una v vi pare che trovi
un kit medico a quanto l'ottanta per
cento del gioco tramite medico dai fate
i seri rega io ho fatto tutto il gioco
senza il kit medico quanti ne posso fare
adesso guarda ce n'era allora il fatto
che per chi non lo sapesse ce n'era uno
all'inizio ma non l'ho visto e se tu non
lo vedi qualcosa non ce l'hai per tutto
il gioco vi pare possibile una roba del
genere non è possibile quello dico io
perché se non l'ho visto e non l'ho
preso vuol dire che hanno sbagliato a
posizionarlo magari sono io scemo quello
sicuro però non puoi non mettere una
cosa basilare di vista dovrebbe esserci
di standard nell'inventario maledizione
ma avete per sfornare
no non sono capace permessa vorrebbe
sempre kit medico prendi usalo ma mangia
lo fai qualcosa prendi usano curati o la
bella siringone a posto gesù esiste
aprista porta niente ragazzi ho finito
il gioco finito il gioco
aspettavo da questo momento da tre live
anzi 44 live che aspetto se questa è la
quarta live minchia o raggiungere attore
si sigla adesso raggiunto quello che
vuole si paga seba gaza la nave è
rimasto aperto il portellone della
navetta posso entrarci dentro aspetti
amo farmi salvare e bellissima sta roba
è rimasto aperto il portellone della
navetta mistica sta cosa
ho appena realizzato una cosa se la
navetta non arriva perché è bancato io
ho salvato e book
ho pagato tutto il gioco
ok dio esiste per la seconda volta
apriti ti prego apriti supplicò che sia
offre ok limite parte no si ok non sono
entrate perfetto se sera vagato il gioco
avevo appena salvato quindi potevo
prendere buttare tutto il giorno grazie
super tia grazi giulia simi so ripresa
dall influenza sono riprese mi sono
ripreso quasi completamente non si vede
io
dai dai ragazzi sono vivo finalmente ho
pochi colpi di fucile a pompa e delle
lancia fiamme però vabbè
se non importa si schianti incinta 62
maggiore cosa c'entra lei dall'altra
parte alla sections innesti per proprio
perché nomi nomi non mi segna quel punto
che strano perché non sbrilluccica il
punto so dove devo andare quindi no
problem un po strano che non brillano
nascono e si sta paghiamo tutto adesso
si ok c'è la stranissima prende
l'ascensore si si si oh yeah mai five
friends sono contento sono il kit medico
sono troppo contento
alcuni si accontentano per per poco io
sono uno di questi ma guarda per la
gioia sparò la prima prima persona che
vedo come il primo che vedo in testa
però anche ok
favi che dici lo finiamo stasera ci
vuole un altro live non lo so non mi
ricordo lo story giocando proprio perché
non mi ricordo niente
però questo secondo me è morto non
benissimo cosa che devo fare lo vedo
l'ascensore ma mi aspetta alta tromba
dell'ascensore
minchia un condotto che collega la tra
questo e il condotto sono al ragazzo con
cui hai parlato noi viviamo
ah sì non ho mica una videochiamata
propri corsi che quel giorno li scuote
tanta roba l'hai svizzerotto come se mi
chiamasse italian 8 grande zio adesso
sicuramente mi ricordano ancora di più
solo per il nome genere
hai una fantasia superuomo svizzerotto
ancora mi mancava
te lo dico complimenti
un saluto a te
e giusto che sono salito di quasi e di
qua la tromba delle scale si
ah ok formalista ho capito ma il
condotto dove ciò che avevo prima porta
sorry sorry successo mi sono dato fuoco
meno male che non furono cucinato io
stasera non era un casino porta in line
loro catlin guarda finisco a
rimisurazione facciamo un po di
c'è allora io il live a portare come
codice d'accesso fra il codice di
accesso mi dà a fare qua punto a portare
serie però e 83 82 punto apportare nuove
serie però ci sono dei momenti tra una
serie e l'altra dove posso fare cose
nuove quindi cosa volevo dire non non
serie tipo rocket league
quindi sì tranquillo sarà qua
seguendo il corso dovrebbe proprio
essere qua se teoria
eccola la tromba dell'ascensore
io non farei questa cosa però va bene
non fa niente ok su good
continua baldi no ti prego zio baldino
baldini mi sparo no no che crolla tutto
veloce che l'acqua di ea valentino fa
tutto giusto
va bene molto bene salsa ritirati tirati
prima che la fiamma ti colpisca giornate
tranquille di lavoro a sevastopol
diventato assassin's creed che belle le
trombe degli ascensori mi piace un sacco
è il mio secondo posto preferito
dopo torino
cazzo mi metto a adesso tra l'altro
quali sono i materiali che mi servono
per costruire il kit medico sono
iniettori componenti b e sensori quindi
ogni volta che vedo ste cose qua mi devo
ricordare che gli servono per il kit
metri a trento non sappiamo e mi fa
vedere o buona roba così non uso la
torcia anche sono la uso mai quindi va
beh se vi alzate io vi ammazzo di spacco
la famiglia così io ve lo dico
anzi vediamo se gli occhi sono se questo
si alza al 100 su 100 ciao
te lo meriti
fai schifo non si cura di carlo sembra
il posto in cui simpatici fanno male e
sarebbe anche ora
a posto sicuro io adesso sì che stai
bene chiesto portello se mi tocchi di
più chi uccido ok
tra l'altro tra l'altro il sensore di
movimento non segna i tipi che va bene
uno ragione di sintetici meccanico
simulator cosa devo fare poteva
accenderlo co demonio ma chiediamo
all'altro se devo fare mi sono
dimenticato sa ma è stata la bartolini
android per raggiungere apollo trovo
lime trofei
credo che l'altro sia ce ne sono proprio
tanti ok se ti muovi dio guarda cosa ti
faccio no perché questi sono i jam
scarpi brutti quelli che dove tutti
stanno fermi così poi un opa orribile
tipo le candid camera
gesù cristo non ce l'ho portato però c'è
quanto tempo
io voto non ci credo
devi aprire riaprire ma non mi hanno
picchiato mi sculaccioni togliti togliti
tu hai affanculo storage prima cosa mi
alzi le mani o denuncio riposo live e
morì quanto tempo e che sta parlando da
attuare senza uno a te sto prendendo
cosi perchè mi ha picchiato mi ha fatto
malissimo quindi devo trovare delle robe
per curarmi e mi hai niente ho sprecato
dei corpi cioè notizie non ti muovere
stai fermo e hard dico se seguiamo lo so
indicatore per una volta nella vita
ho capito che devo andare di qua però a
spegne ma usare il tono faty costa tanto
e ho usato una volta prima gli abbia
fatto una un livido gli ha fatto
cos'è il tonfo lo usiamo per il
carnevale serve a niente
cioè ci ho provato prima non ha
funzionato
magari sono io sbaglio ho sbagliato a
usarlo ci devo ritrovare il nuovo però
mica lo usa una volta non funziona se lo
prendi in cartolibreria alton fa non è
colpa mia e ripristina la corrente dai
fan ha trovato in vinicola stabilirò una
comunicazione diretta con pizza che mi
sono pagato addosso grazie francesca che
laico una tromba dell'ascensore per fare
no aspetta che c'è una scena d'amore
fascino gas complimenti
[Musica]
che minchia sei hulk bravissimo
quest'anno lo capii perché i ragazzi
questo entra in grado di spaccare la
faccia di androidi manco rambo per tokyo
culti così io il manhwa perché l'anime
troppo spezzettata lo spiega bene e darò
sicuramente un occhiata al manga di
tokyo gul
non ho mai ho letto solo l'attacco di
giganti deathnote poca roba let di manga
quindi sì sicuramente ci sono chiare
salve come va oggi giornata possa posso
controllare un secondo computer non le
dispiace molto gentile grazie susan si
chiama situ susan sei veramente bella
susanna e questa cosa mi piace
pochissimo questo qua a sinistra mi
prende tra 3 2 1 non mi ha preso
incredibile portello bloccato è think
ora si cerca di uscire dallo showroom
dei synth ed è uno show room questo
della fiera adelfia a settimana della
moda di milano
vabbè
scusami come faccio mica mi farei
tornare indietro ci sarà un condotto una
roba
porterò bloccato tutto sorella
perché c'è un modo per aprirlo da qua
appuntamenti showroom no opposto cosa
qua che devo seguire ogni volta mi segna
di qua è perché non sono io scemo ho
capito che devo andare di qua non si
apre portello bloccato me lo aprite poi
[Musica]
dove vado
datemi e mezzo consiglio raga dai la tua
mano poi una volta anche da sempre
trovarla io a solution è tornati
indietro e volendo però che palle
trovate voi dai ditemelo voi sì lo so
che non si muove il contorno della
webcam e ogni tanto si frizza raramente
succede però capita c'è un bottone che
si trova dietro la colonna è vero
porca vacca grazie joker strà gentile
dietro le colonne
ok va bene allora cerco dietro gol
sotto la scrivania tutti mi sta dicendo
una roba diversa da un occhiata vediamo
se stavolta siete buoni
vediamo se stavolta siete buoni talebani
abbiamo questo no
ma allora ogni tanto siete utili a orco
demonio o l'appuntamento è sono fa vj
quello che fai video invitano sempre la
festa no la lega non ci credo quanti da
tutti i robot un uomo con demonio veloce
veloce entra veloce veloce apri apri un
modo on the dio che bravo bravo questo è
bravo bravo questo mi devi dare
proprio questo mi devi dare se riuscissi
a rimanere anche protetto nei prossimi
dieci secondi sarebbe meglio ottimo non
mi seguono piu sono ancora noto quanti
colpi ho trovato su cui ho trovato alcun
cosa per creare i colpi no non ho capito
lo sono trovato ad as il fucile a pompa
ma non è semplicemente per cui paghiamo
non ho capito che ho trovato a vestire
non vorrei usarlo adesso visto che lì
appena trovati corpi teniamoli un po
minchia che cagà e andata benissimo
ragazzo era tipo un raduno di quelli che
faccio ogni tanto penso che ricablaggio
servono ma questo bordello qua chi è che
il mora e fa quel rumore li devi essere
in corso attivato a per evitare che ma
tanto non mi seguivano lo stesso
chi è che fa per il rumore o no no no no
non fatelo che era vero
io ci ho provato ma come può
www no dai adesso no no no va bene cos'è
i fantastici quattro ragazzi ci sto male
male come aiuto
no regale va beh dovete morire se il
fuoco vi colpisce non ci credevo chi è
male soprattutto dove devo andare visto
che la porta è chiusa annunciò il codice
d'accesso chi sa che ma come fanno
essere vivi
sì ma se vai a fuoco cioè si coerente
con le due scelte mourinho ma vuoi solo
morire tira che è diventato the walking
android istogrammi così facciamo niente
vi faccio ammazzare che così ha spiegato
troppi colpi faccio ammazzare tanto
recupero da lì e capiscono devi
ucciderli tutti per prendere la tessera
devo ammazzarli tutti sono 80 robot così
diventato sto gioco o transformers noi
in trasformers i robot sono un po più
grossi no lega fate i seri veramente
ammazzarli tutti tutti ma va mi chiama
sono in 200 ma no raga massa che mi
prende per il culo
tutti i robot ma non è possibile non
saprò mai sono tantissimi proviamo col
tonfa
chiama sono tantissimi regali poco non
li fa niente si abbellisce sono più
belli con il pop madonna regalo sono
veramente troppi no e questo l'ho
mancato da un metro
dai no devo ricaricare il tromba porco
schifo tonfa che arma inutile dai vai a
fuoco schifoso l'aido che male sono i
200 ancora tutti devo ammazzare ma le
chiamo vi rendete conto di quanti sono
non so se siete resi conto sono
tantissimi hilton fa non serve a niente
rimangono fermi ma ora con schifo lungo
colpito prima che mi colpisce
non mi sembra un'esagerazione comunque
mi ha finito di fare terminator qua e
sarà l'accesso ci aveva lui poteva
ammazzare solo lui ho trovato io ho
trovato solo lui ci aveva la tessera
cibo grazie ho vinto tutti i colpi del
don fa mi rimangono tre colpi di fucile
a pompa grazie mille complimenti ma
bombay non ho parole per ip giuro sono
scioccato
si corre non stai fermo grado
allora gesù è vero potrei usare le
granate tra l'altro seguì samuel so
dov'è questa navetta tra pollano trova
trova ok ma tornerà a sinistra la
simpson si next exit ok già sprecato 8
milioni di colpi vabbè
in discesa verso la sala programma di mi
ha tolto
c'era gah sono veramente
usare da subito il pompa e la gente mi
consigliava di usare il tonfo che però
non fa niente quindi ho provato a usare
hilton fa perché il pompa è fortissimo
vorrei tenermi li colpi capito il
problema che funzionano solo quando ci
han voglia ma grazie per il family
friendly andato a [ __ ] proton
è saltato
no
ma cosa ce l'ho già passato ora
cavalcano
ok diventato un po metal gear stage all
queste sono le ripeto ancora una volta
ragazze rame sono le porte di monsters
and company della mostra seconda di sole
porte quelli che le apre l'armadio esce
nell'armadio di bambini quei mostri e
cheyenne dall'armadio salta giù
ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi che male
brava zia brava ci hai fatto
fatevi curare che favorendo chiaramente
ma stesso incontro quale lega uguale
identico cioè questa e ditemi se non è
mossa se costa roba logorarmi tanto per
cambiare poi tratto questo anche il coso
livello 2 posto
che bello che c'è pace tranquillità in
un c'è alien che gioia
no ragazzi vi alzate vi sparo in testa a
tutti quanti
non ci credo
proprio libero
aspetto ammazzatemi ammazzatemi
ammazzato il primo rifacciamo ok rifatti
li facciamo la hbo
facciamo così parla
eroico
[Musica]
ok
pensavo si disattiva 0 subito tutti
quanti invece no però vabbè resta ancora
uno ancora uno o la pasta 9 bene
questa parte è veramente orribile aveva
ammazzato mio sono troppi gol
orribile st parte porcaccia vacca se
avessi più colpi non mi farei ammazzare
ma non ne ho tanti quindi va bè te
possino a calder età a tutti aveva
usiamo il condotto subito che è meglio
cioè io pensavo che l'anpi facesse fuori
subito tutti invece no prova beh questo
ricablaggio questo caso per nascondermi
vai qui sotto ciao
esseri umani questi ingegni della natura
iniettori sony
secondo me devo andare dall'altra parte
però intanto poi vediamo cosa c'è ma
forse devo andare io non lo so
se fosse devo andare di qua sto passando
tutto sotto
piano piano piano piano se fai che
ammonti a non dovrebbero svegliarsi
già
gravissimo
vai porco demonio che è successo grazie
della donazione aspetta e che devo capi
sono qua sono qua apri apri mi sono
piegato per bella non portano live set
mani piuttosto mamma grazie di avermelo
ricordato che esiste che domani cosa ha
detto non ho capito cosa aveva detto
perché vi sono pagato bella donazione ok
capisco
aspettava
samuel è troppo pericoloso si no no non
ci credo ma veramente perché tutti sto
gioco tentano di ammazzarmi dai c'è di
ammazzarsi volevo dire non ti ammazzare
non fare questa cosa qua attiva ma
morirai sei scemo è sparito vanno avanti
apollo in versione la creatura non è più
a bordo la stazione anche noi e richiedo
che le operazioni di contenimento dei
rischi vengano sospese
bradley apollo di dare meno e non
potremo rendere il pericolo apollo non
mi pare non sono capace come si fa
come si fa dov'è il cavo rosso e questo
questo tolgo togli
non ci devo mettermi mamma mia che ansia
vairo tolto
meno male che non so daltonico
il gap
lo verde quindi devo andare random ayane
fallo fallo random il 50 per cento
se qualcuno vi chiede di staccare ricavi
non fate di testa vostra che poi succede
questo questo è quello che posso
riassumere bene basta non entrare entro
anch'io cosa e quindi avere un 50 50 e
ho perso era veramente un ciclo che
c'era solo questo e quest'altro quindi a
noi c'era anche questo che pirla che
sfiga o il 50 50 praticamente
dai dai veloci come di star di calma
pole in versione la creatura non è più
richiedo che le operazione di
contenimento veri
che bello
e chissenefrega ammontare calore verrei
a londra molto presto ai propri
il feed ai rossoblù prima
si no
ora tocca a cedere i gravi abusi sta
rendendo le cose difficili
non riesco nemmeno di martino
dovrei fidarmi
si ok basta che mi dice si parli in
senso antiorario
anzi ora
fatto
[Musica]
è vero dai erano facilissimi hanno tutti
in ordini salgono ed allora conosci
seven deadly sins e l'anima che c'è su
un ex no non l'ho ancora visto saluti da
lugano grande lugana è morto samuel
no scusate mi samuel su un robot e io
non l'avevo capito e sta roba
ma quand'è che lo diceva scusami ok
scherzavo tutti sanno essere un roba ok
no che storia non lo sapevo
che la trottola dispiace ma io non so
come ho fatto a non capirlo grazie play
gamer piper a facci dukas indie grazie
mille
una logica visto la madonna
esageratissimo grazie a vero
supergentile troppo troppo troppo
gentile cioè esagera però grazie a me lo
chiedi qualcosa che ti rispondeva molto
gentile grazie cioè porcaccia vacca e
grazie davvero grazie mille comunque mi
chiami giuro non pensavo io non avevo
capito fosse un robot
mi sento proprio deficiente non so come
ho fatto a non capirlo
infatti mi sembra strano che prendeva a
pugni agente gli androidi spaccava la
facciano il possibile
ok è vero io non avevo mai capito grazie
ancora play gamer davvero no no no no no
scherza va beh
veloce veloce sono i migliori far tutto
veloci veloci le nazioni
ok
tranquilli ragazzi avete sonno perché
tanto va dai che rimane sul canale per
sempre quindi potete recuperarla
no provo
questo c'era anche prima ma non l'avevo
visto mai mai l'avevo mai visto ok
perfetto va bene
chi è l'aggancio ci sei rimasto
malissimo non avevo proprio capito un
deficiente vabbè la navetta posso
tornare indietro granché
giuro mi sono perso stamattina me la
ricordavo neanche dalla prima volta che
l'avevo giocato come possa essere così
stupido e disattento mannaia quello non
equa che minchia siamo
cioè mi devo rifare tutto il contrario
che palle no per penso che ci sia un
punto dove che mi posso di fare tutto di
nuovo la roba lì arrampicandomi a posso
andare con la pedana anche sull good
minchiate lasciamo messo un'ora
magari
questa conversazione voglio dei dati la
protezione che stiamo benissimo
potrei accettare queste condizioni che
cazzo
ho sentito
mamma mia che ansia che anzi assurda
let's go chissà quanto manca raga avete
più o meno una idea della percentuale di
gioco qui siamo così tipo 80 per cento
veramente non me n'ero accorto io adesso
vederlo lo so anche molti di voi ma io
giuro l'avevano detto sicuro mille volte
in ogni non aveva lanciato un sos a
trovare in isolamento a distanza c'è un
campo caldo
vai ok devo andare all'unità centrale
quindi dai
80 per cento va bene
armi da fuoco e quindi devo portare le
armi siete scemi come si sa quanta roba
ciò addosso sì ma me li ridai vero qui
da me li ridai le armi però per favore
mi servono
si è chiuso è chiuso
più o meno ma la doppiatrice di ripley
non sembra la stessa di eli è vero un po
potrebbe essere potrebbe essere la
stessa di lasso fallo sapere che non ne
ho la più pallida idea disattiva il
comporto bene
scusatemi problemi che avevo passati
a
49 30 sordi nuovo visto e tanto guarda
intanto tanto guardo lascia perdere e la
fanno iniziato il gioco che mi pio
scazzotate in faccia quindi no problem
sono tranquillo sono le armi tra l'altro
beh dico
chi altera d'altra parte deve esserci
qualcosa che posso prendere utilizzatore
successo
rai va bene va bene
che
minchia si aspetta che devo capi in
attimo mi sono tirato da roba
[Musica]
ma chi è che perché cesta musica qua
grazie linda grazie mille
se quindi sei bellissima anche tu grazie
nella foto ci sei con un ragazzo quindi
a lui non farà piacere che tu mi abbia
detto questo però grazie
apprezzo tantissimo hanno cercato di
entrare nella mia capirà il controllo
che noi siamo spariti i loschi bastardi
penati per le gestioni gli android non
avresti dovuto dire di meglio
infatti morirò è fighissimo che sta roba
ti indica la direzione non nuovo capito
lo spento l'ho già fatto l'ho già usato
le cose per spegnerlo lo stato già prima
l'ho usato prima che due volte me lo fai
da te perché prima dovevo fare prima
l'altro va bene ma ho rifatto
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
veloce prima che schiatti vai
però ci veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce nicchia pensate se sta
andando al centro e la nasa tanto sono
pieno di armi erano già adesso l'avrei
capito ad esempio riccardo l'entrata
principale bloccata idee sulla prossima
mossa
ricardo edizione se mi senti trovo un
altro modo per cui
vai a ok non possiamo dirlo
una maschera grazie di dio devo arrivare
qua per arrivare qua devo fare tutto un
giro che ora faccio da una parte lo
facciano all'altra
va bene basta che non mi spunta il tipo
davanti porco schifo che kakà ma farlo
in modo più tranquillo no allora avanti
allora oggi un condotto che va a destra
ci prova dai buy
è chiuso non ci credo dai veramente aprì
a prima aveva si cominciava i secoli fa
e si concia paesi con chabal corri corri
corri corri corri corri corri corri
corri di qua
che anzi ecco lo aiuta veloce però che
sta arrivando a gente perfetto nola lo
molla romano mollano ok sta andando
molto bene
strano rispetto al solito ok ma ce ne
saranno altri sicuramente figurati vai
tranquillo non mi prende sono stato
bravo regali
no minchia che kakà non l'ho visto ma la
mia o la io non ho colpito l'altro
quindi io devo fare proprio
io stanno per farlo
perfetto
vai vai vai vai vai perfetto zio so good
mi chiamo andata benissimo stravolta dai
vai entra se dio vuole
c'eravamo io continuo a salvare perché
mica go
chi sa quanto è difficile da creare
strada
no è impossibile ridurre il sistema di
sicurezza come faccio cerca di ridurre
il sistema di sicurezza di apollo come
lo riduco sistema di sicurezza ha tra
l'altro non è neanche il caso che mi
segna i pasti dove la gente quindi wow
come riduco sistema di sicurezza qua
dentro
caccia vacca
[Musica]
c'è ma io non ho neanche assile grana
tempi cielo in questo momento potrebbero
essere strout i li devo ridurre sistemi
sicurezza da un secondo
devo andati qua credo sia quello in modo
spietato state zitti non secondo come
com'è possibile se tirato lamp in bocca
ma sti cosi qua funzionano quando ci
hanno voglia
scusami no
sai che palle
si vabbè e ogni gente radio mannaia
aspetta come come si riducono di quasi
di sicuro e cosi stato attivo far vedere
sistema di sicurezza o perché sono
puntino ridurre
alla consolle della sala ok grazie a
farmi soffrire un po ogni giorno un
bacione la recam grazie cam your socute
gentile tutto e io cerco di fare il mio
se ci riesco sono contento grazie mille
e anche se loro andassero con sarebbe
meglio però sono androidi solo lunedì e
il mercoledì
oggi che giovedì non lo sono quindi non
lenti non funziona va bene
quindi devo tornare alla sala c'è
figurati che giro mi fanno fare sti
mongoloidi che palle
si si lo so vicino al condotto solo sosa
ma solo capire come arrivarci weight
allora aspetti qua
sono perché era condotto kiss
eccolo
c'è dentro
e questo mi dice batteria scarica
sequestro
ah ok questi top
non so no stop assassino qua o questo mi
ha attivato le cose spetta vede e si
pensi
potevo fare qua bilanciare cos'è sta
roba per cedesse averli non ci arrivano
rinvio per confermato bloccato avis che
bravo allora e sono appena arrivato ho
trovato il medic it ha voglia ha voglia
di ovaie bello questo te lo dedico
guarda ti devi corsa siringa fan non è
una cosa bella da tre o quattro vado
merito questo è il medico siringhe o si
l'ho trovato è stato e quello è stato
quello l'obiettivo trovato posto la
batteria scarica
ecco allora mi chiama è diventato
difficilissimo anche la reale roma ok
no ok
minchia ci ho messo un'ora e mezza da
fast aggregata qua ci pensate voi
file età in perché oggi ne voglia di
evitare i video
è riuscito anche il video editato quindi
fatto fatto fatto marco fatto fatto
ragazzi tutto fatto tutto giusto o
adesso c'è un ora e mezza funzionava
anche quei compiti di matematica sta
roba quando andavo a scuola e duravano
pochissime prendono sempre due poi è
gesù da dai consultiamo apollo che sarà
di nuovo lì si apre tra l'altro a preti
a paolo rossi gira tutto no non si gira
forse si apre in qualcosa
e simpatico apollo paolo paolo combina
guai
la navicella tu sei
va bene
non c'è nulla di meglio che guardarla
live con una bella cioccolata calda
anch'io vorrei per me l'ha però se bevo
non gioco quindi beati voi che potete
vedere veramente e non giocarvela
soprattutto per gli infarti va bene sono
una posizione estremamente comoda per
godermi questa cosa hai visto erano
d'accordo
volevano tenerselo sto potuto alien
ispezione al redattore centrale
esci dalla parte del nucleo di apollo
rai alla parte inferiore acea scala
addirittura situ sorella migliore
costruisce
c'è ma
quindi era tutto organizzato sin
dall'inizio pensate che pezzenti ma
insomma a gesù
vado al reattore si tanto devo andar lì
massi due o tre cene o cosa
qualcosa mi fa venire amatori mi
dispiace
lo siamo tutti se scoprissimo quando
siamo soprattutto dopo la risposta parte
civile vabbè in tutto questo.io ho il
tonfa elettrico e basta
ok
nel ripristinare la corrente ottimo
ripristinate la corrente per cortesia
agli androidi faranno qualcosa sti
maledetti android che palle
ecco ed è morta troppa gente la simpson
ha venduto tutto quando che loro
sapevano tutto persone solo per soldi
non sei più quello di una volta che
caratterialmente minchia manuale
rimanevo così mi ma mi ammazzava a
quest'ora numero prima si cresce
life is life and
al in italia però io vorrei nuovo le mie
armi visto che tanto so che andrà a
buttare tutto è vero oggi non si è visto
ancora li ed è grazie a minchia se no
facciamo una roba fatta bene tu te ne
stai dove stai
datemi un qualcosa per ricaricare hilton
fa almeno ciò solo questo silvio è la
chiave però la chiave fa ridere da rega
almeno per ricaricare il tonfo schifosi
duri di pezzenti e non so il non c'ho i
colpi del tof no o demonio no
devo entrare quadernò torciglioni
necessaria che ovviamente non mi sento
veramente una persona stupida a volte mi
ha bloccato mentre tentava di dargli la
mazzata in testa ai a chiamare vabbè
sono i proiettili non è eccolo la torcia
ioni preghiere nord veloce che c'è
quello veloce non devi cambiarlo qui ma
66 stupida io che ci devo fà nicchia lo
prende lo guarda guarda la data di
scadenza guarda tutto è vabbè allora
fate la lista della spesa pure co
demonio e poi come faccio scusami che
giusto qualche mi segue non faccio mai
in tempo non scusatemi la rinuncia
faccio già farò mai
ma impossibile ma neanche fa in tempo a
fare il gruppo primo fondo figurati
si sta menando però forse ce la faccio
nonostante mi stia menaldo vi furono ben
filologi darglielo in testa che vale ai
entra dentro
ok se sei veramente scarso zio
mamma mia
il piano è come la femme salvarlo praga
tutta sta parte qua me la devo fare
senza armi prima senza medici di ma
senza armi
sì lo so regala che l'animazione della
webcam di fianco non sta funzionando ci
stava in tanto succede non c'ho voglia
di riavviarlo va bene da guardia top
allora
beh visto hanno un aspetto messo quella
grossa
ho sbagliato
vabbè dai poi lo faccio che palle
comunque veri che non è che non funziona
che devo riempire flasharla un attimo ho
messo con la grossa devo mettere quella
più piccoli è appena la prossima live lo
stesso die ma non c'ho voglia davis fare
veloce zio il tipo veloce devi fare
veloce più veloce di così severamente
lenta dio mio
poche palle dio mio c'è la gente devi
muovere il culo non puoi fare le cose
lento ogni volta mamma mia che fastidio
e nuovi stage aperto ogni tanto capita
sorella non scarico
a
ho messo l'orario per quale motivo
valori piscina corrente dispositivo un
valido dai va bene mi dà una botta
veloce e me ne vado che è bruttissimo da
dire ma questo l'ho già usato quale gli
altri posizioni
torna indietro veloce
io
a posto devo capire cosa aprire
rimaniamo alquati che non si stanca che
palle esca dai condotti per favore no e
non posso uscire se ci sei tu non posso
uscire non strisce raleigh dentro per
cercare bene o male
l'altro se n'è andato tra l'altro
manuale parola spetta interessi si
dovrebbe essere rotto le palle
speriamo perché sono un casino
ok
capita sì
puoi girare da un'altra parte
per cortesia bravo bravo ok sei fermati
fermati bravissimo allora dove devo
andare
quello l'ho già fatto manca l'altro
perché non chiedano riguardo i
protocolli di sicurezza di saperlo mi ha
visto no
ma mi sa che non mi ha visto va beh non
è questo questa è chiusa
eccola purtroppo messo un'ora ma l'ho
trovato veloce della cena ci facendo
veloce veloce però
vai tiralo però veloce veloce prima che
arrivi tira
tipo tua sorella attivato tutti quindi
dovrebbe funzionare adesso se fai
si no però c'è il bello che io mi
immagino lui che mi sculaccia da dietro
fortissimo perché non avrebbe senso sono
state ok ho attivato tutto ok
almeno qualcosa è successo fatica
infatti schiaccio che può perché sei un
deficiente fatti i cazzi
in breve tempo
just a parte che non difficile
[Musica]
questa è una violazione
lol lol non l'avevo visto la botola di
sotto non avevo visto assolutamente la
botola 18 tutta sta parte senza kit
medico ragazzi come facevamo far come
facevamo come facevamo a farla era
impossibile era impossibile
tutta sta parte senza kit medico era
impossibile
meno male che l'ho trovato sono era
difficilissimo
mi chiama fatto tornare qua figure
ok porca vacca quanta gente bene bene
male che sono andati via sblocca la
porta sblocco tutto sblocco tutto frate
sì mi servirebbe trovare cosa per
sbloccare la porta mi dà una mano
per idea
ha chiesto insomma gli dai una mano
milano
il demonio sì però non devi guardarlo
come se lo stessi comprando all'ikea
wolfgan questo gioco è diventato molto
più interessante improvvisamente va bene
[Musica]
68 32 quindi il codice c'abbiamo 68 32
dai va bene
no
non lo voglio usare di nuovo quando vuoi
usare di nuovo il bolt action perché ciò
tre colli voltri anni e con tre colpi
quindi se posso non usarlo è meglio 68
tra i 27 32
se io potrei diversi computer e
dispositivo non valido tua madre morta
non è morto muoiono quando hanno voglia
come sempre porco schifo non si è aperto
lo stesso rega nonostante il codice non
si apre non si apre ad esempio
le altre armi che fine hanno fatto
quando sono entrato qui dentro mi hanno
fatto depositare quindi non ce l'ho più
purtroppo
quindi non era sotto 3 2 per quella
porta e per cos'era 68 32 scusa mi
aspetta devo leggerlo perché non so
allora sei scemo il codice del sito 3
allora a [ __ ] e quello è eppure cosa
mi dice che devo andare lì qua che
strana ammonizioni bodgan perfette come
se dovessi ancora fare qualcosa qui o il
badge forse era quello no non sono i
volti a un ottimo sono ovunque io l'ho
visto il coso mimì fa sarà ancora qua
l'on ok
dovevo sbloccare la computer le portesi
me va bene
boh io continuo a non capire come mai
non mi fa aprire quella fottutissima
porta però vabbè niente dove vivere per
forza là dentro
devo vivere in quella stanza non ci
voglio andare in quella stanza
questa è la stanza di accensione otto
ore non ci voglio stare qua dentro
mamma mia che ansia rega
si sia appena rischio salvo ragazzi si
ce l'abbiamo fatta
basta ce l'abbiamo fatta
ho fatto una parte della destra
ma quindi scusatemi io le mie armi non
li riprendo fiume delle trovo così ce lo
trovate in giro praticamente già usato
683 due regate più
chi è favi tiro ragazzi scusatemi non
avevo letto nulla perché lo concentrato
insegue tempi rosolen da noi grazie zio
non sia più quello di una volta 6 meglio
grazie però non so no è vero che bello
di qualcosa a qualche android ei sistemi
di controllo centrale mi sa che devo
andar lì va dovrò esplorare il livello
inferiore
ecco lo hanno trovato
porterai under the hill ma la storia non
giocare che sta morendo non puoi giocare
fino alla vecchiaia ma lo dici tu dici
tu caro mio
il tappeto aspetta però prendi in prendi
la mira fatta bene
e allora non è proprio giornata
c'è qui buchi nella fascia devi morire
per ha insegnato colonna guarda amore
conduce buchi nella faccia mori si fa
così siamo coerenti bene
sì però io non è che posso fare certo
quello che butta giulia non posso far
terminator ma va bene tutto cielo la
revolver perfetto la facciamo così
guarda
[Musica]
le nozze di spari in faccia devi stare
fermo di stare proprio fermo devi dire
cazzo mi ha sparato in faccia nel mentre
che dici cazzo mi ha sparato in faccia e
diverso vicino capito che funziona così
è la vita trascorsa in faccia una
persona no sono tornato indietro che
mongoloide
[Musica]
e vabbè dai fa niente toccatemi fate il
cazzo che volete della nostra vita
perché devo passare di qua
[Musica]
non me lo ricordavo st parte io giuro è
un casino
c'è poi un sacco di roba non me la
ricordo io mi ricordo proprio niente
visto gioco molto bello co demonio che
botta ha dato ci siamo
per renderti ragazzi dovete solo
aspettare
aspettate e vedrete aspettate vedrete
chiesta gente beve non so sono haters si
rincorrono ed ai e perché non è più
fatto vivo con pietro è sparito pietro
per un periodo però adesso
ritorniamo ho già capito cosa sta per
succedere soprattutto perché ho appena
trovato dei lanciafiamme e questa cosa
qua non è proprio il massimo
mi sa che gli le uova di alien
[Musica]
c'è un problema paure si chiama est a
parte raga non me la ricordavo mai giuro
mai ma ricordavo sovraccarico del nucleo
alfa ci sono 8.000 alien adesso chi è
che voleva vedere alien dall'inizio
della live ecco mi sa che mi sa che
siamo è aspetta che c'è gente grazie dio
ha prezzo
mi sa che sa che
co demonio
a posto ci sono dei ragnetti che fanno
schifo che non è proprio il massimo però
va detto che una botticella e vanno via
meno ma almeno quelli se ti guardi le
palle scoprire che si muovono non penso
di averle perché sono una donna alle
spalle intendevi gli altri quando gli
altri così sono qua spetta dov'è l'altro
3 comando
ecco a questo quello che ho già attivato
quale mark secolo lino alla leva sorry
no non celate allora eccolo qua
era da tanto qua non c'è ali non ci sono
i consigli di alien credo è più mi
ricordo se torna ad incalzare duro mio
amico come miccia col gioco
ok
ragazzi esami
[Musica]
via via via via via via via via via via
lo gesù cristo gli ho dato fuoco però
nel mentre è sparito quindi è sparito
per seggio ha dato fuoco
ecco fa grossi ti do fuoco spariscono
nel mentre che che mi prendono che culo
dobbiamo muovere il culo fortissimo
stato la partita cielo sono
sopravvissuto a due alien due c'è culo
ecco perché tornava lì e non è che torna
yen
ci sono altri alien non devo correre non
devo correre ragazzi mi sa che non devo
correre
minchia
ok non corriamo non corriamo non
corriamo incorriamo non corriamo
corriamo non brevissima roba di non
sappiamo e non corriamo
non corriamo no non corriamo minchia
meno vorrei che ci sono i lanciafiamme
qui
minchia rega che brutta storia e di
madonna
siamo tornati in un momento un po
concitato
meno male che chi soffre di cuore
richiami di cuore è andato a nun finisce
che moriamo però mi sono salvato due
volte come un alien davanti tre anzi ci
sono tipo 3 o 4 alien ma secondo me
anche di più porco schifo che kakà chi è
poi tratto secondo 6 cammino con
lanciafiamme mi sento nomi sentono
salutano ammazzato dice prima avevo dato
delle fiammate delle potenti mi ero
salvato per miracolo
adesso no che sfiga tremenda
con la bosnia con la volte grande
secondo voi mi date mi date una
consiglio con la bottega non li faccio
male per qualche strano motivo
scrivete meno perché non mi va di fare
un test visto che spreco un colpo molto
importante
come hai fatto a dimenticare questa
parte ma sai che se non lo so mi
chiedevo essere proprio smemorato bello
forte perché dimentica mila parte non lo
so come ho fatto
marca vacca esploso luogo ci sono gli
armadietti neri dove puoi nasconderti lo
so se ti farò una chat e forum o male lo
so
quindi stiamo in mano col fucile a pompa
nostra parte poi immagino che ci sia un
salvataggio ogni dieci ore quindi ottimo
c'è un salvataggio pa no minchia che
kakà perchè aliena così brutta non lo
trovo molto sexy
se guardate le belle gambe non sparo con
la bordo bolt gay non usare il tonno al
tonfano rusal tofano fa male bancario
pani ladro o gesù christian qua non
capisco se c'è gente
una donna di carmen sì ma un salvataggio
ogni sei ore
ok
la vodka nancy la tengo in mano non fa
male cioè non fa rumore
solo col lanciafiamme lo vede tanto
viene di questo per forza
salva veloce
che culo toglilo veloce via t
l'inchiesta parte un casino regalo da
parte veramente impossibile tira i
comandi comandi non c'è corrente fa con
c'è corrente da nova come rega noda
aiutati serie adesso parliamo seriamente
come non c'è corrente non c'è corrente
ma cosa no mica st parte na roba
allucinante maron casinò usa 2 e si che
sei morto hai un buon motivo per esserlo
borja trottola meno male a non mi sa che
uscito dall altra parte mi possono
ficcarsi nei condotti allora per chiara
viene così sexy è per le gambe si guarda
lo tra le gambe
tanta roba genova
ora c'è la corrente posso girare sti
cosi e figura di novi sono andato la
fortuna mi sorride più o meno non sempre
solo il mercoledì per salvare la partita
chemical co addosso
[Musica]
ok
dai porca vacca
s
mi sa che ho sbagliato la direzione però
vabbè
quanto ci fai che 3321 mi spunta satana
davanti questi affari one shot a un
regalo non li devo sottovalutare ma
neanche per sbaglio andrai verso dove
c'era casinò mario gori
orco demonio
la pistola ho tirato fuori in un il
lanciafiamme la pistola
la pistola dei della chicco occorso
perché ho detto mi che arriva a gli
sparo con lanciafiamme era quella di
idea ho tirato fuori la pistola
vabbè vabbè
che cazzo
c'è una roba che vedo attraverso il muro
come un capisco sarà un bug
[Musica]
nicchia sembro ciari izzard volta non
corro lo stesso anche se va bene
mamma mia che brutta
sesto bordello qua
chi è
mi chiama non esco mai più regate ci
metterò sei anni e lucia di qua parte
che c'è la madonna dal 3 st porta va beh
posso provare a salvare di nuovo
dov'è il salvataggio
dai dai dai minchia non peggio
[Musica]
porca vacca st parte lega che è brutta
che brutta el'ascensore dai dai corrida
non posso correre
va bene ma perché io parti pagandole
perché io perché ha il pompa in mano
quando l'hai cambiato ma perché è solo
un metro quindi chi se ne frega ma
cristo di dio il pompa cosa te ne fai
non avevo quello madonna guarda malora
show dove molin spa rinfaccia lasciami
vieni qua dove sei
cerco dove sei niente pezzente ma che
cosa non vieni e ci avevo il pompare le
guardo cretino raffigurati c'è dio non
ho parole veramente ci aveva il polpo ha
cambiato arma lui lei c'ha voglia
la piccola nome quasi
eh ma mi piace morire
devo fare un contratto con gli androidi
quindi wire grazie mickey non c'è
bisogno davvero basta di serio cioè non
basta davvero fatti di scherzi grazie
mille
sinceramente mi dona capito e mi vuoi
bene supergentile di questi ragazzotti
che però basta davvero non c'è bisogno
grazie mille
che vedevo di se non questo sayonara
colpa allora figura
c'è mica quanti siete
i ragazzi e palle l'uomo giro
dove mi onora non ho un kit medico cielo
ma devo fare devo fabbricarne wow
simpatica questa cosa
facciamo tutto un giro strano per
andarli a ma era anche qui che
mongoloide aspetta
[Musica]
dai vieni
detto
dal 3 qua l'altro devo fare
lo farà no
ma devo fare prima uno poi l'altro vabbè
con schifo
ci sono arrivati prima gli androidi non
troppo no non so come si faccia sta roba
che palle
vabbè
c'è ma vero
vero
nove regate
lo demonio non so come si fa ecco
infatti allora
tanto
non ho colpi di niente se non il
lanciafiamme bene a gesù
nora che non so fare questo giro
fammi uscire cambiano lavoro
cambiano
sì perché non lo sapevo fare
sabato 02
adesso mi sa che si smaterializzano
tutti se indirizzo la corrente vero può
essere che si smaterializzano tutti
arriva
attenzione attenzione attenzione come si
smaterializzano non può essere mai abbia
lo svuotamento vabbè che sta lì
patrono no non posso difendermi con
tossico ha però almeno non dovrebbero
avermi preso
devo anche muovermi secondo me
grazie
e se non si apre pure questa anno devo
avviarlo da qua lo scemo
non salire sa di sale
non devo salire che cosa vuoi che faccia
devi parlare però perché devo devo
capire dimmi parlami cosa c'è al via lo
svuotamento dalla sala controllo nel
reattore come si arriva alla sala
controllo del reattore
da qui però questa chiusa a ok cellulare
nuovo visto ma vedo
[Musica]
io
dai dai finiamo sta roba porca vacca
c'è
vai mio dio
lo spaccato che vignali
[Applauso]
mi sa che non è finita però vorrei
salvare salvatemi salvare la partita
molto bene molto bene
mi dispiace ricordo
se io ho capito ma dovrei curarmi cioè
dovrei scusami salvare la partita perché
se metti che muoiono rifarmi tutto il
pezzo degli androidi prima c'è un
salvataggio da qualche parte non abbiamo
spaccato gli anni abbiamo spaccato tutti
gli annunci non lo so cosa sta
succedendo fatti mi trovo un salvataggio
veramente il salvataggio di pietro
[Musica]
va bene ci abbiamo provato a spaccarli
tutti sono continuano a vivere
vabbè salvataggi qua credo che la
prossima sarà sicuramente il finale
sicuro per forza di vedere dove c'è il
salvataggio eccolo le boe abbiamo fatto
molto bene e volevo uccidere gli alien è
sì ci avevo provato amici sono contento
certo meglio andar meglio d'acqua
ragazzuoli spero vi sia piaciuto è stato
molto carino mi sono divertito un botto
mi dispiace se ho iniziato un po in
ritardo ma dovevo mangiare fare la pappa
e niente dai e facciamo che prossimo
prossimo è l'ultimo sicuro infatti
faremo sicuramente una parte alien
nell'altra parte faremo domande risposte
magari passeggero perché non mi va di
fare alien e poi fare un altro gioco
quindi vediamo dai niente spero che
finisca bene non mi ricordo come finisce
buonanotte aria buona notte con la notte
ma una notte con la notte
noi ci crediamo
[Musica]
chiudiamo un prossimo video grazie
esserci stati mi dispiace perché mi
stavo divertendo usano che si fa un po
tardi giustamente dove andare tutti ci
vediamo alla prossima notte noto a tutti
ciao belli e ben ali sia